let's play a game
how many potatoes do you think are grown
in ontario each year i think you'll be
amazed at the answer first let me give
you some hints there are 125 registered
potato growers in ontario they grow on
approximately 38 000 acres for city folk
that's just over 150 square kilometers a
lot right so what do you think 1 million
pounds 10 million pounds don't guess yet
here's something else you need to know
ontario farms grow red white yellow and
russet potatoes they're sold fresh
through grocery and food service
channels as well as through the process
market this includes potato chips and
fries knowing this what do you think now
100 million pounds 500 million pounds
ontario potato growers produce around
800 million pounds of potatoes every
year and the majority of this crop stays
here only a small fraction around 5 is
exported get inspired to eat your fair
share learn more about ontario potatoes
at producemadesimple.ca